salut aujourd'hui je vous parle de mon
top 5 des chaînes youtube que j'aime
bien parce que vous le savez le mental
blog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un
an là on est à la 77e et le jeudi
je parle de ce que je veux et surtout de
ce que j'aime je suis plein de chaînes
youtube je suis tous les jours pleins de
chaîne youtube ça me prend un temps
incroyable mais voilà c'est ma nouvelle
télévision youtube carreman en même
temps quand tu as décidé de faire une
vidéo par jour pendant un an tu es
obligé d'être en immersion permanente
enfin tu peux pas t'empêcher en fait
c'est très intéressant mais bon je me
suis dit deux choses je me suis dit je
vais faire deux vidéos d'un coup c'est
pour ça que j'ai habillé comme hier et
avec la même lumière qui hier ce parce
que je pars en fait pour une date
donc pour être sûr de moi je vais faire
les deux vidéos d'un coup enfin c'est
pas que je le fais ce que je le fais et
je me suis dis surtout que j'avais vous
parlez des cinq chaînes que j'aime
beaucoup regarder qui n'ont rien à voir
les unes avec les autres y en a qui ont
moins d'abonnés que moi il y en a qu'on
est beaucoup plus que moi voire même et
l armement plus enfin voila j'ai pas
pris comme critère le nombre d'abonnés
ça n'a rien à voir avec mon choix il ya
des gros il ya des petits ya de tout et
c'est parti je vous emmène avec moi la
première chaîne où je vous emmène c'est
jane fait son cinéma
alors jeune c'est celui d'amy en fait
hein on se connaît mais c'est pas pour
ça que je vous en parle c'est parce que
vraiment ces vidéos sont très originales
jeanne c'est une personnalité vraiment
vraiment à part entière allait
différente de tout ce que vous
connaissez
ne cherchez pas on a fait une vidéo
ensemble tout début de mon mental blog
elle a fait d'ailleurs une vidéo qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle jeanne s'est
faite mentaliser alors à la trouver une
solution pour que je ne puisse plus vous
mentaliser je vous spoiler pas je le dis
pas regardez c'est celle ci jeunes s'est
faite mentaliser voilà s'est lancé dans
le blog récemment elle parle de tout en
fait c'est une personne qui écrit des
scénarii voilà pour cinéma a l'air fou
là-dedans ça marche bien pour elle et
elle tient ce blogs podcasts on sait pas
trop quoi à côté c'est très rigolo avoir
une de mes préférées c'est jane fait la
sirène je sais plus laquelle s'était
aussi je crois que ces briquettes la
bonne année ah non j'aime le remplace le
père noël celle ci est là à là des
petits mots gentils pour les enfants qui
m'ont fait vraiment rire devant le
téléphone en fait le demeurer
jeanne faits sont destinés mas et ses
209 abonnés 209 abonnés elle devrait
avoir 209 mille abonnés cette meuf c'est
sûr j'ai une amie youtube buzz qui dit
que ça va devenir une star de youtube
mais là
donc et ça m'emmène sur la deuxième
chaîne que je veux vous faire découvrir
le corps la maison et l'esprit de
laetitia alors laetitia ll poste encore
plus de vidéos moi c'était moi j'en mets
une par jour elle elle peut en mettre
deux à trois par jour ça arrive
elle peut tout faire est là elle a
énormément de catégorie dans ses
playlists
il ya quoi il ya avec mes potes les cinq
ans de réflexion ça c'est super elle a
un bouquin en fait où ces cinq ans de
réflexion durant cinq ans tu écris des
choses le lift pose des questions on y
répond et une fois que tu l'a fini tu
leur fais une autre année et comme ça
durant cinq ans donc tu revis dans quel
état d'esprit tu étais les années
précédentes est ce que tu es devenu en
fait c'est hyper chouette ça je regarde
avec beaucoup de plaisir mais découverte
aussi j'aime bien mes blogs en voyage
elle fait énormément de voyage avec
farid ou thé son mec il est mortel et il
est en train de prendre le pouvoir sur
cette chaîne l'éthicien fait très
attention à paris d'où il ya mes
expériences bio puisque en fait allé
dans le moins consommé aller dans le
zéro déchet ce genre de choses donc elle
a des astuces très intéressante
les concours qu'elle fait c'est anti
soit voilà les mini blog du bonheur ça
c'est sur sa vie et on y voit souvent
farid'o justement découvert l poste
énormément il ya plein de contenus il ya
toujours des choses à voir
c'est le corps la maison l'esprit en
fait à la base c'est une blogueuse
laetitia et elle a créé sa chaîne
youtube
en parallèle du blog et puis ça se
complaisent super bien petite cerise sur
le gâteau cette meuf est juste
extrêmement gentil elle prend le temps
de répondre à tout le monde
on s'est rencontré elle a fait une vidéo
avec moi sur sa chaîne j'en ai fait une
haie avec elle sur la mienne elle est
hyper accessible à est toujours prête à
discuter à donner des conseils à donner
un coup de pouce c'est une déclaration
d'amitié laetitia public et la chaîne de
vérino ça c'est mon troisième
ça c'est la troisième chaîne dont je
voulais vous parler il n'y a pas d'ordre
d'ailleurs dans les chaînes que je vous
donne je les aime autant les unes que
les autres
vérino il fait une vidéo tous les mardis
qui s'appelle dis donc internet et il
prend un thème de la q1 sujet voilà
quelque chose c'est pas forcément de
l'actualité au sens littéral du terme
c'est l'actualité large ça peut être la
sortie d'un film un truc dans sport un
vrai faits de société et tous les mardis
à 18 heures il a mis en ligne alors il
ya une particularité c'est qu'il est
tournée en public à la fin de son
spectacle le samedi soir il a un grand
écran elle public derrière lui qui le
voit sur l'écran évidemment et il le
fait comme ça en live donc toutes les
semaines il est écrit et après il prend
le risque de le faire
sur scène une fois par semaine tous les
samedis soirs donc si vous allez voir en
spectacle vous assister au tournage ça
c'est super c'est mortel et tous les
mardis à 18 heures banda ton rendez vous
vérino il a fait partie des deux
personnes qui m'ont motivé moi faire des
vidéos départ il ya ya ya à peu près un
an
sauf que jean zay une par mois et encore
pas tous les mois ah là il fait partie
des personnes à qui je dis merci merci
vérino de m'avoir poussé au cul pour
faire ça c'était cool et du coup tu as
créé un monstre puisque je fume be telo
par jour voilà vous pouvez vous abonner
à sa chaîne si vous l'êtes pas déjà
abonnés vraiment c'est cool c'est
vraiment cool
la quatrième chaîne dont je vous parlais
la pâte elle pas besoin de moi cette
chaîne pour avoir des abonnés cette
pierre cros il à 497 1629 abonnés
au moment où je vous parle 497 1629
c'est énorme je crois qu'il ya un an et
demi
pierre il avait géré quinze vingt mille
abonnés sur sa chaîne et à la fin de
l'année il en avait 200 milles où vous
oui 200000 cessa 200 milles il a dit à
300 mille abonnés je fais une vidéo par
jour pendant un mois
il les a eus au mois de février donc
durant un mois il a fait une vidéo par
jour et là est depuis il est passé à
presque 500 milles c'est énorme ce que
vit pierre est énorme mais c'est tout à
fait mérité il fait maintenant cinq
vidéos par semaine donc c'est des vidéos
fun c'est toujours drôle il n'y a pas un
thème spécifique tu vois il n'y a pas un
angle il prend un truc qui le fait
marrer et il fait une vidéo là dessus
mais c'est surtout il ya beaucoup de
formats différents il a il y aura il
fait aussi les choses avec les slides ça
c'est un truc qu'on aime bien il fait ça
aussi sur scène en fait c'est sa marque
de fabrique
les hyperx il a plein et il a plein de
très très bonnes idées à huy fait des
vidéos participative aussi il ya plein
de la ce blog que vous voyez là il est
allé chez marc dorcel pour essayer un
casque de réalité virtuelle pour
regarder un film de réalité virtuelle
également lé mourir de rire cette vidéo
je crois qu'elle est interdite au moins
de 18 oui il a fait on ne demande qu'à
en rire aussi femmes d'ailleurs c'est
vrai il a fait les vidéos et vous
demandent souvent aussi votre avis en
fait sur facebook
ils demandent de la vie de gens sur quoi
vous voulez une vidéo demain il a fait
le lendemain il fait un gros gros tape
dessus quoi mais ça vaut le coup c'est
vraiment très très bien et du coup bas
abonnez-vous à sa chaîne si ce n'est pas
déjà le cas mais je pense que c'est
comme si je vous dis
et vous connaissez gad elmaleh site
humoriste moi c'est le gad elmaleh
d'internet card est la cinquième et
dernière chaîne dont je voulais vous
parler c'est celle de michael hirsh j'ai
pas pourquoi vous fait voir ce que vous
avez le retour écrans en même temps
d'ailleurs michael hirsh gelé découvert
à au festival d'avignon chez les voir
son spectacle c'était vraiment très très
très très très bien on n'a pas gardé
contact après et puis un jour je suis
tombé sur ces vidéos je vais envoyer un
message
il est venu à la maison on a discuté on
a fait une vidéo ensemble sur ma chaise
et parce que j'étais tombé en kiff en
fait sur ces vidéos c'est un respect
c'est un podcast mais qui est
complètement dans l'univers de michael
qui est qui est quelqu'un qui a un
amoureux de la langue en fête du jeu de
mots mais c'est pas du spa du jeu de
mots pour du jeu de mots il ya un vrai
fond derrière il ya un vrai maniement de
la langue et du sens des choses et fait
des podcasts qui s'appelle lettres ou ne
pas l'être lettre ne pas l'être c'est
très très agréable à regarder ces
différents aussi de ce qu'on peut voir
sur youtube ça change un peu et c'est ça
qui me plaît en fait dans youtube c'est
qu'on peut voir des choses qui sont
radicalement différentes mais toutes
aussi intéressantes les unes que les
autres
la dernière qui a fait c'est oui ça se
sa lettre à zlatan la lettre à steve
jobs est aussi bon en fait elles sont
toutes bien michael toutes les lettres
sont excellentes
de là à dire que des timbres et quand tu
veux je fais une vidéo - quand tu veux
voilà c'était les cinq chaînes dont
j'avais envie de vous parler aujourd'hui
celle que je regarde au moins
quotidiennement je regarde d'autres
aussi mais celle ci je vais quasiment
toujours les jours dessus voir s'il ya
une nouveauté quelque chose
jeanne mais des nouveautés ya passé une
chose sur ta chaine michael c'est pareil
on voit on voit pas ce qu'on a tenté
lettres en fait elles sont très très
bien faut que tu en fasses beaucoup plus
en même temps j'ai aucun conseil à
donner à personne assez juste que j'aime
bien ce que vous faites donc plus y en a
plus chevelu euros j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu vous a donné envie de
découvrir d'autres choses il ya
forcément une ou deux chaînes que vous
connaissiez pas dans les cinq que je
vous ai cités pensez à vous abonner à ma
chaîne ya le locaux qui apparaît je sais
qu'on vous le dit tous mais c'est
important en fait d'une part c'est très
très motivant pour continuer à faire les
vidéos et d'autre part ça permet que nos
vidéos sur un peu plus mise en avant et
ça nous aide à nous faire connaître
voilà vous savez enfin pourquoi on vous
saoulent avec ça et demain on sera
vendredi donc je mentalise ray quelqu'un
donc rendez vous demain à 17h pour
prochain mortal blog ciao